les forces russes intensifie donc leur
frappe aujourd'hui neuvième jour depuis
le début du conflit en ukraine notamment
sur les principales villes et la
bataille des ports se poursuit notamment
à marioupol on va retrouver tout de
suite notre envoyé spécial cyril payen
sur la route de kiev qui se trouve à
bilad servent à ça fait trois jours que
vous roulez vers kiev la capitale qu'est
ce qui est le plus marquant pour vous
bah écoutez ça fait effectivement trois
longues journées qu avec george s bec
nous traversons ce pays en étant entré
vers par l'ouest par la frontière
polonaise est en fait nous faisons
exactement
le contraire du voyage que font des
dizaines de milliers peut-être plus
d'ukrainiens pour fuir coûte que coûte
cette zone de l'oblast nous sommes donné
désormais arriver nous sommes à quelques
dizaines de kilomètres de kiev donc
trois jours assez ça manque un peu de
croiser dans l'autre sens c'est bien des
longues files d'attentes de voitures de
gens à pied et il est vrai que depuis ce
matin
pardon nous avons fait de 300 kilomètres
et on a changé véritablement de paysages
au moment où je vous parle il ya un
convoi qui vient de passer avec des
chars montés sur des sur des des camions
nous avions nous sommes là depuis
environ dix minutes dans cette ville de
l'oblast une voiture de police est venue
immédiatement vérifié nos identités donc
on sent bien qu'on a changé villa
évidemment de d'endroits par rapport aux
zones comme vive la frontière polonaise
où c'est surtout l'exode qui est
important il ya aussi les barrages
toutes les quatre ou cinq kilomètres des
barrages qui ne sont plus des barrages
d'auto-défense de miliciens plus ou
moins armé plus ou moins mini d'uniforme
mais là ce sont les parachutistes c'est
l'armée ukrainienne qui étaient à pied
d'oeuvre donc on rentre bien et bien
dans le l'épicentre un qui entoure la
défense de la capitale de kiev il y a
encore le sud cette voie sud par
laquelle nous arrivons à kiev ray la
voie ouest qui n'est pas menacée
directement ou encerclée par les forces
russes mais c'est ça aussi aujourd'hui
la grande menace qui pèse et on a vu
donc cette accélération de cet exode il
y avait pour l'entrée pour la sortie et
l'entrée pardon de la ville où nous
sommes et bien des kilomètres de
véritables kg m 2 que deux voitures qui
attendent pour partir quitter cet
endroit donc il y à un exode massif qui
est en accélération depuis évidemment
les événements de la nuit autour de la
centrale qui se trouve à 400 km
centrales nucléaires qui se trouve à 400
kilomètres au sud en crimée où il ya eu
des des combats qui affole beaucoup la
population on a extrêmement peur de
cette centrale je rappelle qu'il ya
quinze centrales nucléaires en ukraine
et que celle ci est une des plus grosses
d'europe donc une une grande peur
également aussi des déclarations émanant
du ministère de la défense ukrainien aux
premières heures de l'aube parlant à
quelques dizaines de kilomètres de là on
se trouvait bien du parachutage de par
deux de trop par porter ruche tout cela
qui est évidemment paraît difficile
quand on sait ce qui a pu se passer ces
derniers jours avec le l'arrivée de
troupes aéroportées russes en avant
poste 1 dans d'autres endroits les
environs de kiev où ça c'est extrêmement
mal passé on le sait puisque le convoi
qui devait les soutenir n'ai jamais
encore arrivé donc évidemment beaucoup
de volatilité de rumeurs sur place
extrêmement tangible consent dès qu'on
arrive ici à seulement 10 quelques
dizaines de kilomètres de la capitale
ukrainienne et pourquoi le convoi russe
des blindés des chars en avance t-il
toujours pas
les écouter c'est en tout cas la grande
question qui permet de raffermir je
dirais les défenses de kef les défenses
des grandes villes puisque aussi toutes
ces villes sont totalement maintenant
fortifiée il y a énormément de barrages
en construction qui sait sur des villes
qui se bunkérise un même si on peut voir
là nous sommes en plein centre un
semblant de vie normale mais ce qui
prédomine ce sont des hommes en armes
l'armée et puis des civils des civils de
te défends c'est bien qu'ils
construisent des ddd bout des bunkers
effectivement il semble que ce long
convoi qui a tant affoler les
chancelleries occidentales qui attentent
affolé kiev et qui devait fondre sur la
capitale ukrainienne il semble que
d'après les renseignements militaires il
y ait deux pour des problèmes qui
n'était pas prévu évidemment qui d'ordre
logistique et que ce qu'on voit
évidemment soient coincés c'est un
convoi qui implique des centaines de
blindés des centaines peut-être plus de
soldats russes et qui n'a pour l'instant
ne faut pas sûr la capitale donc
évidemment c'est une opportunité que
saisissent on le voit bien toutes les
forces d'autodéfense toute cette nation
et ça aussi c'est ce que nous avons pu
voir avec georgia ce bug depuis trois
jours à traverser ce pays en guerre ce
pays qui est attaqué et bien cette
mobilisation nationale qui est
absolument incroyable qui était
certainement pas le scénario il faut le
dire prévue à moscou lors de cette
attaque qu'il ya plus d'une semaine
maintenant une mobilisation incroyable
qui est presque total tous les gens qui
restent ici que ce soient des femmes des
hommes de tous les corps de profession
quelles que soient leurs d'olive yens
socialement et bien quand il reste c'est
pour s'engager pour la défense nationale
pour la défense du pays c'est
extrêmement nettes et apprend à mesure
que l'on se rapproche de la capitale
c'est de plus en plus net les gens qui
sont ici le son pour défendre le pays
pour beaucoup il désire ont décidé de ne
pas partir merci beaucoup cyril payen
pour toutes vos informations merci à
vous